[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce qui fait courir
jean-françois faye est apprenti
boulanger à 16 ans à seulement 40
il est à la tête de plusieurs dizaines
de magasins qui porte son nom
alors que la guerre des franchise de
boulangerie s'intensifie que va-t-il
continuer à multiplier les petits pains
il est 6h45 du matin et les premiers
clients sont impatients en notre bonheur
parce que comme celle à l'ouverture on
pense que on va bien être quand même je
me suis renseigné un peu j'ai regardé
sur internet
apparemment ils ont l'air de faire bon
produit donc voilà on va tester
feuillette ouvre sa 36e enseigne à
colmar sa dix septième franchise vers la
première cliente bienvenue chez nous
jean-françois riches fraîchement
licencié de l'enseignent fly s'est lancé
dans l'aventuré
je sais pas si on a beaucoup dormi mais
réveillé très tôt
vers 1h à peu près et avec ben
du stress et de l'impatience mise de
départ
1,2 million d'euros investis avec une
ancienne collègue elle aussi licenciée
on est sur un concept différent des
autres c'est aussi cela qui fait le
succès aujourd'hui des blanches de
fenêtres se retrouvent dans des choses
avec des valeurs mais différent un peu
de tout ce que je veux dire du mass
market
le big boss est déjà là attentif au
moindre détail
jean-françois tapas la petite règle et
oui la belle à petit règlement tel mais
je le cherchais une comme ça dommage que
en fait là la pâtisserie c'est qu'une
question de détails
donc c'est c'est important là par
exemple on a imposé d'installer
toute la pâtisserie avec une règle ce
qui permet d'avoir le même écartement
entre chaque gâteau et c'est ça fait des
jolies vitrines des jolies présentation
du côté du fournil fleurant formateurs
du groupe feuillette encadre l'équipe de
boulanger alors les ficelles s'asseoir
super look derrière les gars vous
on est les petits pains les petits pains
spéciaux offre à cuire avec les
sandwichs nous relancer une tournée de
ficelle dans la foulée et vous pensez
surtout vague est un on n'oublie pas que
tu allais complaire à cet homme ça jacki
h avec tt l'expert l'expert de la fis
7/10 menu acheté pour la vente c'est
dorian 24 ans qui accompagnera pendant
plusieurs jours
la nouvelle équipe de 17 salariés
éventuellement ce que je peux te laisser
faire ça allait récupérer des croissants
ou des pains au chocolat sur grille
alors tu vois s'il ya de la pastureau
charge et sinon tu peux les ranger à
côté du four il ya un rangement la juste
sur le côté à droite
en fait à l'ouverture d'un magasin il ya
toujours une partie des motions
d'adrénaline et eon comme
on cherche toujours avoir avoir des
nouvelles émotions et des voix là et
c'est toujours un cd défilé challenge
géant
on a envie de ça et on a envie de se
nourrir de ça c'est la tradition pour
l'ouverture que l'enseigne reçoit la
visite de l'équipe municipale et le
maire est tout de suite intrigué par les
photos accrochées au mur les photos
c'est des vrais photo de famille ouais
dont vous voyez la petite la petite
faute aulas et ses maisons que j ai fait
ff c'est jeanjean feuillette et françois
feuillet c'était maison que pour ça que
mes parents ma fille je pense que
l'enfance contribuer peut-être au fait
d'avoir une énergie une niaque
supplémentaire c'est vrai que moi j'ai
j'ai toujours eu envie de d'avancé c'est
important pour moi quand j'ai démarré en
pâtisserie j'ai tout de suite voulu
aller travailler dans les dents des
grandes maisons j'avais ce besoin
d'aller vite d'aller loin s'il met
facilement en scène sa famille
jean-françois feuillette n'aime pas
parler d'ascension sociale
et pourtant à 23 ans il rejoint pierre
hermé le célèbre créateur des macarons
du même nom à 25
il a envie de voler de ses propres ailes
et débarque à blois où il achète avec sa
femme sa première boulangerie revendu
depuis c'est vrai qu'on a été vraiment
charmé cette ville de blois est juste
juste incroyable et puis ce magasin au
pied du château
on a tout de suite été conquis
quatre ans plus tard la boulangerie
feuillette est devenu un concept est
produit tout ce qu'elle vend à blois un
laboratoire approvisionnent les magasins
ici on fabrique 10000 macarons par jour
5 tonnes de beurre frais arrivent chaque
semaine de touraine et la fierté du
patron ce sont ces noisettes importés
directement du piémont italien
il ya beaucoup d'eau aujourd'hui de
boulanger qui achètent leur palin et
nous le parfum le goût du praliné
il est unique parce que c'est nous on le
maîtrise on maîtrise le produit on
maîtrise les noisettes ont maîtrisé à
vendre on les sélectionne et on fait
notre praliné on fait notre produit le
praliné
c'est ce qui fait le succès du paris
brest 1 classe de l'enseigné le bout de
votre part et brest il est unique voilà
vous le trouverez vous aurez pas ce goût
là ce bout là on travaille le produit
comme on le même mois le produit je
l'aimais comme ça et c'est comme ça que
je veux qu'il soit dans tous les rayons
c'est super les gars vous avez bien
bossé le groupe feuillette c'est
aujourd'hui mille personnes en france et
les compagnons de route du début sont
toujours là comme ghislain le directeur
du labo préfet quand même temps 13 ans
13 ans 13 ans qu'on travaillait ensemble
c'était mon apprenti mais c'est vrai
apprenti vtm c'était mon apprenti
il a bien évolué et a pris quelques
kilos entre temps on va s'y ranger un
peu trop du gâteau le laboratoire
emploie 75 salariés pour une fabrication
à grande échelle mais toujours
artisanale se défend jean françois
feuillette
j'ai toujours dit que la limite du
développement ce serait la qualité c'est
où on arrive à faire une qualité dans
plusieurs magasins on n'y arrive pas et
on fait pas depuis plusieurs années
c'est angelo musa le monsieur pâtisserie
d'alain ducasse qui supervise les
recettes et aujourd'hui c'est la tarte
au citron qui est sur le grill contient
pas de conscience aux saveurs e'lara
malien peur ces titres on s'est revu sa
mère du délicat et c'est un produit qui
est compliqué mais c'est clair mais
comme quoi mais on le sait on le sait
c'est un produit tarte citron
ouais
l'expansion du groupe ne fait pas
seulement des heureux les petites
boulangeries s'inquiètent pour leur
avenir
c'est que feuillette n'est pas le seul à
multiplier ses implantations ici à bois
nord il ya aussi pâte à pain marie
blachère et firmin c'est la ville qui a
vendu le terrain pour que y est un choix
assumé par le maire c'est la loi du
libéralisme on peut pas à la fois
défendre la liberté d'entreprendre que
je soutiens et puis condamné ce type de
concurrence entre des groupes comme le
tien et d'autre et après ce qui fait la
différence c'est l'appréciation des
consommateurs pour le patron de
feuillette la concurrence ne serait pas
là où on pense la boulangerie feuillette
et a une grosse activité sur la
restauration rapide parce qu'on a des
espaces de 100 120 places assises
c'est vrai que ont fait aujourd'hui 50 %
de notre activité entre 11h30 et 14h30
donc on n'est plus des concurrents des
enseignes de restauration rapide plutôt
que des boulangers retour laboratoire
trouver une nouvelle recette de tarte au
citron
c'est le challenge du jour pour angelo
musa le pâtissier d'alain ducasse et
ghislain le chef du laboratoire la pâte
sucrée 28 la crème moelleuse
on va mettre un biscuit noisette édition
mettra notre boule de meringue qu'on
fera souffler au four à 250
l'idée c'est d'apporter du plaisir et
des milliers de personnes et dans toute
la france
c'est ça qui est aussi excitant et de
conseils ça ça donne envie d' d'aboutir
le produit n'est sur la part la partie
finale la décoration donc on partage les
idées un peu
il a sa vision du labo donc il a une
voix plus précisément ce qu'il veut tu
veux pas que tu sers est joli cela c
magnifique tôt
[Musique]
ce feuilleton c'est l'heure du verdict
en présence du patron et du responsable
recherche et développement
je suis très très bon j'adore l'acidité
du citron donc je trouve ça vraiment
très très bien le fonds est top moi je
trouve qu'en d'épaisseur en on est on
est bien on a très bien vous aplatissez
en fait oui l'homme bout de marin et
aplatit oui les charmes oud luth a bâti
moi je trouve ça je trouve ça beaucoup
mieux le fait de la platière je trouve
qu'il ya plus de régularité sur cet
article
c'est une bonne idée les gens savent pas
à quel point on passe on passe un temps
de dengue à être à être là tous ensemble
a essayé pierre cesson c'est son nom
c'est son nom c'est son job à temps
plein par exemple le baba au rhum qu'on
a on a mis trois mois pour essayer de
l'avoir pour moi pendant trois mois je
faisais que ça touche
dans quelques semaines la tarte au
citron aura peut-être sa place dans la
devanture du futur magasin de pithiviers
où il enseigne s'installe à la place
d'un resto asiatique talent accès
directement comme comme d'habitude sur
la partie à boulangerie avec la
visibilité sur le fournil qui va être
ici la porte d'accès qui sera là pour
aller derrière la barrière l'âge la
caisse et là c'est un accès direction
parce que là la ligne de caisse ligne de
vente vient ici les délais de travaux
sont réduits au maximum trois mois pour
une rénovation six mois pour une
construction
le pâtissier boulanger que je suis il
est toujours présent parce que je pense
toujours côté pratique quand on
travaille dans un labo moi j'aime bien
que les plans de travail soit une
certaine hauteur il faut que ce soit
pratique pour travailler pour les pour
les salariés donc c'est tous des petits
des petits détails mis bout-à-bout qu'on
améliore à chaque fois la structure et
la décoration des magasins sont
identiques cheminée fauteuils en cuir
boiseries et papiers peints le client
doit se sentir comme chez lui
une charte à respecter donc on peut le
voir sur le sur les finitions dans
l'ensemble à 99% ça restera la même
boutique
[Musique]
c'est ici au tout nouveau siège du
groupe dans la banlieue de blois que
sont choisis les villes susceptibles
d'accueillir une boulangerie godefroy
delahousse le développeur présente la
prochaine implantation à saintes en
charente-maritime
on a 25 mille habitants d'accord une
agglomération de 60000 habitants
donc c'est un dossier qui pourrait
potentiellement être prêt en franchise
ou en succursale et on est sur un axe
ici avec onze mille onze mille véhicules
jour et on est vraiment sur leflux
effectivement qui va vers l'autoroute et
qui va effectivement vers toute la zone
la zone d'activité avec des locomotives
alimentaire c'est la plus grosse zone
commerciale de simples exactement une
langue le bailleur est plutôt
compréhensif il est ok pour faire
éventuellement trois ou quatre mois de
franchise de loyer
d'accord je cherche aujourd'hui
activement
en loire atlantique je cherche également
à bordeaux et je recherche aussi
forcément dans la région centre pour le
réseau succursaliste et je recherche
pour tous les franchisés qui veulent se
développer des codes de la start-up
jean-françois feuillette a adopté le
baby foot dans le hall de l'entreprise
mais aussi un appétit de croissance qui
n'a pour l'instant pas de limites
on a beaucoup de chance dans une
entreprise jeune dynamique et on a des
gens qui ce qui se donne tous les jours
qu'ils sont là
à nous porter et à me porter évidemment
c'est incroyable un petit rêve que j'ai
en tête c'est c'est quand je voyage
il ya des fois j'ai l'impression de voir
des boulangeries fenêtre partout et je
tiens je verrais bien donc c'est
peut-être de mettre un petit pas en
dehors de nos frontières
reste à savoir combien de temps il
pourra conjuguer croissance et qualité
les deux critères qui ont jusqu'à
présent assuré son succès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]